Student: Hi. Doctor Peterson. Mother . my question is
I know you mentioned in a lecture uh last that the importance of setting goals in life
Physician Peterson: Architect
Student: Um, to kind of goals to work towards, right?
So my question was: how do you do it, if you do not know where you want to go?
Because, this is kind of where you suspended your authoring program in the future, because ...
Doctor: Well, that's a good question, that's a really good question. Mother ...
I think it is echoed to some extent, in the structure of biblical stories, in this way.
So the idea in the Old Testament is that morality follows a series of taboos.
There are a bunch of bad things you do not have to do, and then basically good.
I think there is wisdom in it, I think this kind of children start, right? You are-
I mean, I love children and all, but they are crazy little creatures, and they must be, united.
Well, what you're doing is putting a ban on them.
Often what you are trying to do, is a prohibited ban on them,
For behaviors that if manifest, will make their lives miserable.
So, I have another chapter in this book I write, called "Do not let your kids do anything, that would make you hate them."
The idea is there, that your job as a parent is ...
Help your children become a group of 4-year-olds, so that adults will smile honestly when they enter a room.
Because that makes the whole social environment sincere and welcoming.
Thus, your job is to make them desirable social objects. Much of that is a ban.
Well, there is this moral shift.
It happens, to some extent, in the tradition - in the prophetic tradition,
Where there is a spirit that looks, in some sense, higher than the law.
But there is a real shift between the Old and the New Testaments,
Because the Old Testament is a prohibition, the New Testament is ...
"Well, here are the good things you do, one more than just banning yourself from ..." from the rampant sin, let's say.
There are good positives to be, ah, completed.
Well, you might say, "Well, I do not know what a positive good is!"
Just enough man oh!
So ... for this reason, this thing that I said to people, this MIM has become through the Internet crazy,
But this to clean your room and ... [public laughter]
It is much more useful than people think! It's also much harder, but ...
The first thing you do, I think,
I learned this part of Solzhenitsyn, was trying to settle his soul, when he was in the Gulag,
Because he was trying to figure out how he got there.
How they contributed, and how they got there.
You know, not Stalin and Hitler, although they were blaming, you know, but ...
He could not do much about it.
I think what you need to do, this part of modesty,
Do you have to look around you, within your sphere of influence,
Such as, direct impact sphere, repair objects that declare themselves as needing reform.
These are often small things.
You know, and can be, like ... your room. Put it in order!
Because the thing is, it is not very important, that your room be arranged, though it is.
What is important, is to learn, how to distinguish between chaos and order,
And be able to act in a way that produces the system.
In most homes, there are 100 things to do,
Let us make it less terrible and terrible.
Thus, the practice of this is a real beneficial form of meditation.
It is also - it is also ... I think it is a divine act, because you take chaos!
You know, if you notice a room, it is very exciting.
And I learned - because I've restored many places now, try to make them beautiful.
One of the things I've really learned is that even if you have a structure,
Unless you have investigated all corners and corners, cleaned and put your mark on it,
And made it your kingdom - it is not your own.
Just the fact that physical property does not make it yours!
You must create a dynamic relationship with the objects, before they are actually yours.
I think you can do something as simple as sitting on your bed and thinking:
"Well, maybe there are 5 things I can do today, so ...
Tomorrow morning a little better than this morning was, or at least I'm not lagging behind. "
Usually it is ... like having to eat a frog in the morning, right?
It's like, it will not be something you want to do, there will be things you are trying to avoid.
They're snakes, basically.
But if you ask yourself, just as you ask someone, I think it is a form of prayer,
If you ask yourself instead of telling yourself, as you know,
"What can I do, to set things right today,
Will I actually do it? "
It's usually a small thing, because you're not disciplined, you know.
Then you can go to do it!
And then, you ... put the world together a bit more,
When you do this, this spreads,
But you also put you also you adopt yourself in something,
This is better able to call the system out of chaos.
This makes you more and more powerful!
The next day, maybe you can do a little bigger job! And...
Like, you get the compound interest benefit, if you do, it's a very powerful technique.
I think that if you do, at some point, rather than just fix things, that's not good;
You will begin to get a glimmer of positive things you can do,
Positive things you can do, which will actually form a vision.
This is what I would recommend.
Student: Thank you.
Dr. Peterson: Well, good night. [clap]